Y esta es una de las épocas más
difíciles de nuestra Unión Europea
nuestra Unión quiere fortalecerse y ser
fuerte para las crisis pero nunca
imagino esta crisis esta amenaza
una guerra en nuestras fronteras
y la paz fue puesta en peligro y los
conflictos violentos volvieron a Europa
unas semanas después
del comienzo de la guerra cuando Francia
tenía la presidencia europea nos
reunimos
y la pandemia y la guerra han puesto en
peligro esta soberanía Europea
y también la han mostrado la solidaridad
que quiero decir hoy
Qué significa todo esto en el contexto
actual la Euro la soberanía europea
puede parecer una palabra rara por
algunos años este concepto ha aparecido
como una fantasía francesa quizás una
ilusión
después del discurso en las hormona en
septiembre del 2017
ya hablaba yo de la soberanía Europea
pero
quiero que estas palabras sean centrales
para mi proyecto de gobierno
también las raíces de esta soberanía en
los Países Bajos Este es un concepto muy
europeo
más de unos hace más de unos 50 años
aquí en la haya uno de los fundadores de
la modernidad política Baruc Espinosa
escribió un artículo en él
los cito el derecho se divide entre el
poder de las multitudes y lo llamamos
soberanía
no voy a dar una clase sobre Espinoza No
se preocupen pero solo quiero señalar
que en la filosofía de Espinoza la
soberanía da un sentido de ser todos en
una sola alma
quiero insistir en que la identidad y la
soberanía están entrelazadas
y pienso que es muy importante entender
este vínculo y el hecho de que Espinoza
lo constituye en uno de los conceptos
fundadores de la filosofía
política Porque si uno acepta perder su
soberanía significa aceptar depender de
otros poderes
es ponerse en la situación en que uno no
puede decidir por uno mismo y no puede
hacerse cargo
de preservar y desarrollar su propia
identidad
defender la soberanía no significa
dejar nuestras vidas significa elegir
Cuáles son nuestros socios y darle forma
a nuestro propio destino por eso decía
que hemos sido testigos de la evolución
dramática de este mundo debemos entonces
tratar de hacer las reglas con base en
esta soberanía y debemos
guardar nuestro espíritu de apertura y
asociación pero durante la pandemia ya
se habló de esto descubrimos que
dependíamos de una cantidad de
elementos externos y
tuvimos que acudir al respeto y a la
cooperación
tuvimos que comerciar con nuestros
vecinos aunque no fueran nuestros
aliados con Rusia para la energía porque
decidimos de hecho que el comercio podía
ser una buena manera de cooperar que se
que podía crear
vínculos
Pero ellos decidieron
usar la energía como arma y nos pusieron
en una situación increíble
esta guerra nos empujó
a descubrir que teníamos que reducir
nuestras dependencias
si queríamos avanzar
y esto converge de cierta manera con la
idea de que
la Unión Europea
estaba manejada demasiado con un
concepto del cliente y no con el
concepto del productor y el ciudadano
tampoco sabíamos Cómo asegurar nuestra
seguridad económica también quisiera
hablar
de que aunque esto no tiene nada que ver
con el proteccionismo si quisiera
definir en unos pocos minutos
que es lo que podría ser estas doctrina
de la seguridad económica comprensiva
que obliga a la Unión Europea
a guiar nuestra acción globalmente
necesitamos protegernos protegernos
proteger nuestra identidad y poner a
nuestros ciudadanos
a definir
el modelo futuro para mí
esta nueva doctrina debe basarse en
cinco pi
el primer Pilar es bien conocido
pero quiero insistir en esto
que es uno nativo de la Unión Europea de
su competitividad
y una integración europea mejor y más
fuerte Este primer Pilar es muy
importante porque no puede ser un modelo
de rol fuerte no se puede promover la
identidad no se puede uno defender a
largo plazo Este modelo europeo si no
somos competitivos y no nos ponemos en
situación de ser
los que
produzcamos las mejores soluciones por
eso la competitividad es necesaria y por
eso se requieren la reformas refiriendo
a lo que pasó al comienzo de nuestra
charla hoy voy a contar una corta
anécdota para ilustrar no se puede vivir
en un continente si uno decide no ser
competitivo
voy a usar la competitividad para
nosotros Porque se se hace daño a la
economía
y no ser competitivo también implica no
producir más localmente Cómo producir
aviones carros o incluso softwares si no
somos competitivos los clientes que
somos todos no pueden
rechazar esto
Todos quieren comprar a precios justos y
para producir en Europa y comprar
productos europeos Hay que ser
competitivos
se requieren entonces reformas se
requiere Innovación
hay que mediante las leyes laborales
proteger a la gente pero se requiere la
flexibilidad para ser competitivo en
este mundo
Francia en un momento perdió el
equilibrio
hace unos cinco seis años
nuestra tasa de desempleo la pudimos
bajar de dos puntos y
en cuanto a la reforma pensional tema en
el que no voy a profundizar por supuesto
Esta es una reforma bastante compleja
pero tenemos regímenes especiales para
algunas categorías
que para las cuales no se justifica eso
tenemos que acabarlo porque tenemos
deudas de un déficit actual que va mucho
es mucho mayor que el de ustedes
y pienso que los contribuyentes no van a
aceptar que financiemos un modelo social
con estas impuestos europeos tenemos que
buscar esos fondos localmente
el paso de la edad de 62 a 64 si comparo
Bueno pues en muchos países es mucho
mayor mucho menos los países de Europa
la edad de jubilación es mayor a 64 años
las reformas son necesarias
Si queremos seguir siendo productores en
este continente tenemos que saber
producir nosotros mismos al mismo tiempo
ahora tenemos que insistir
en la simplificación de La regulación y
también tenemos que invertir en la
educación superior y la capacitación
porque lo que es clave para la
producción que es una palabra muy
innovadora es tener
actitudes
fuerzas para que los ciudadanos locales
o los que llegan por migración
sean capaces de pertenecer a este
sistema queremos ser soberanos
y quisiera que todos adoptáramos esa
doctrina de la seguridad económica pero
para todo esto se requiere una mayor
integración europea
tenemos que ir más allá del simple
comercio tenemos que integrar nuestros
mercados cuando se crea una empresa una
startup en uno de nuestros países ahí
tiene que cumplir con 27
reglamentaciones en algunos sectores ya
sea en China o en Estados Unidos
el mercado nacional en estos grandes
países es obviamente mucho más grande en
Europa lo que tenemos
que promover es Este mercado único
y cómo hacerlo todos juntos
La idea es construir un enfoque común si
es más esencial en la financiación
la financiación de nuestra economía
será más crítica en un mundo innovador
porque se requiere más capital y sea y
todavía no estamos bien equipados
tenemos una muy buena regulación europea
es Sí también hemos tenido muchas crisis
pero seguimos siendo muy fragmentados
necesitamos una mayor y más fuerte Unión
comercial tenemos ahorros en algunos
países Pero estos ahorros no están bien
repartidos y asignados
necesitamos invertir en las pequeñas y
medianas empresas
Si queremos asignar los recursos en los
lugares adecuados donde se requiere se
requiere que haya una integración del
mercado de capitales y ese no es el caso
hoy nuestros ahorros están en algunos
lugares muy ricos pero no
están adecuadamente asignados
tenemos que basar nuestra competitividad
y nuestro futuro
y esto significa una debilidad entonces
nuestra doctrina de seguridad económica
requiere la integración Europea
el segundo Pilar
es tener políticas industriales
antes esto era un tabú en Europa porque
el pilar el primer Pilar era suficiente
el primer Pilar que misionera El Alfa y
el Omega de nuestras políticas
económicas
era prohibido tener una política
Industrial
porque era una era una intervención en
los mercados era algo que podía crear
sesgos pero ahora lo necesitamos por qué
Porque nuestros competidores hoy están
interfiriendo en los mercados y porque
tenemos que acelerar
y porque nos hemos puesto en una
situación de Gran dependencia
debido al desequilibrio entre el mercado
y la intervención pública en Europa
expresemos esto con un ejemplo
si no se tiene esta política Industrial
no se puede crear
progresivamente una autonomía para
reducir el riesgo energético sería
imposible si no tenemos
si no hay intervención o interferencia
política
en la política Industrial no es posible
crear la propia en la industria pero no
podemos
fortalecer nuestra propia industria de
los semiconductores
y no se puede promover la una paz
duradera con un mercado sin política
Industrial los Estados Unidos la tiene
China lo tiene necesitamos una política
Industrial europea esto no significa que
nos convirtamos en autárquicos pero sí
se significa que hay que tener mayor
autonomía o mejor o diversificar mejor
las dependencias para no quedar Atrapado
en lo en situaciones inmanejables
las políticas industriales
son críticas en varios Campos
quiero insistir en uno solo
a energía
durante el año pasado
hicimos un trabajo colectivo maravilloso
diversificamos
nuestro suministro de gas dependíamos
demasiado de Rusia pero
diversificamos las intervenciones en el
mercado y buscamos nuevos proveedores de
gas
se requirió una nueva estrategia para
reducir progresivamente nuestra
dependencia y construir más nuestra
propia base energética esto significa
que sí se puede reconciliar el clima
la soberanía y la industria
creando nuestras nuestra propia es
Esperanza energética básicamente menos
consumo mayor eficiencia energética
Innovación
también más producción en suelo europeo
y más energía nuclear en suelo europeo
Esta es claramente una política
Industrial que estamos poniendo en
práctica y que tenemos que establecer
porque tenemos que crear subsidios a
nivel nacional y federal para
acelerar estas políticas
de otra manera los incentivos de corto
plazo no tendrían en consideración
elementos sobre el precio la
independencia la soberanía y el cambio
climático eso es una política industrial
Allí se tiene que reunir la Industria
del clima y la soberanía
segundo Todas las energías y las
tecnologías
se requieren para enfrentar el cambio
climático no resistimos al cambio
climático con muchas regulaciones
cuando progresivamente se le pide a las
personas que hagan cambios a través de
regulaciones Sí esa es nuestra agenda
eso lo hemos definido y decidido a nivel
europeo pero tenemos que producir
soluciones en nuestro suelo y esto es
crítico Si queremos reconciliar el
cambio climático la industria
y la creación de valor económico en
nuestro suelo y encontrar otros modelos
sociales porque no se trata solamente de
que no hay suficiente producción si no
se produce dinero Entonces tampoco se
puede saber cómo se va a distribuir este
dinero y esto es crítico si nos
enfocamos en el cambio climático tenemos
que producir las soluciones
Y eso es lo que está pasando ahora en el
medio ambiente actual se requiere esta
industria esta política industrial de
Europa para llegar a la industria cero
carbono
para promover esta industria
este cero carbono tenemos que saber Cómo
distribuir los subsidios
Cómo establecer este marco regulatorio
para atraer la innovación máxima en
nuevas industrias para manejar y llegar
a esta neutralidad esto es crítico de
otra manera podríamos perder nuestra
soberanía y nuestra habilidad para
decidir
Tendremos que ser neutrales en el 2050
pero los chinos utilizan tecnologías
no las utilizan en las estadounidenses
porque esto acabaría con sus empleos no
podrían decir no podríamos decir por
nosotros mismos bueno y lo mismo pasa en
el campo de la defensa
tenemos que definir una industria común
y tenemos que mejorar la organización
Necesitamos este enfoque desde la ley
sobre semiconductores mayor producción
en este campo hasta la industria cero
carbono hasta la ley de Industria cero
carbono este segundo Pilar de una
industria de una política Industrial en
Europa es una clave
no quiero prolongarme mucho pero quiero
decirles que
esto es lo mismo para todos los Pilares
si no queremos ser muy dependientes
queremos ser abiertos queremos buenos
socios pero siempre queremos estar en
una situación en que podamos decidir
no depender de nadie y pasa lo mismo en
la agricultura y en la agricultura
modelo competitivo frente al cambio
climático en la agricultura
la importación cada vez mayor de
productos que vienen de países menos
restrictivos o menos exigentes ese eso
termina siendo un fracaso
entonces necesitamos una política
Industrial para nuestra agricultura
precisamente para producir aquí con
nuestras reglas y para que nuestros
productores hagan más por eso a nivel
europeo hemos defendido una
planta proteica para producir más en
nuestro continente el tercer Pilar de
esta estrategia
es la protección la protección de
nuestros intereses
Este es el lado defensivo de esta
ofensiva estratégica que ya mencioné
tenemos que aceptar proteger los
intereses vitales
cuando consideramos que pueden estar en
riesgo
cuando hay acciones o prácticas
contrarias
por primera vez la Unión Europea se ha
equipado
con una herramienta
para invertir en compañías estratégicas
es todo un cambio ideológico hasta hace
muy poco
consideramos que está que éramos
abiertos pero no teníamos condiciones
ahora reconocemos por buenas razones que
se necesita un
filtro de estas inversiones extranjeras
de acuerdo con un punto crítico
a veces algunos estados tenían que
vender activos críticos por ejemplo las
compañías energéticas
pero todo esto es pasado ahora decidimos
hacer algo distinto la infraestructura
crítica seguridad cibernética donde
consideramos que hay vulnerabilidades o
donde la seguridad nacional y europea
está en riesgo tenemos
todo el derecho a tener este mecanismo
de protección activar este mecanismo de
lo mismo se aplica en otros Campos como
de la defensa de las tecnologías y
pienso que es muy importante y Considero
que esta es la manera
Esto es lo que nos lleva a seguir
estos cambios en la educación y la
cultura
siempre hemos defendido el discurso
libre la expresión libre
las libertad de los contenidos Eso es
parte del modelo europeo pero cuando no
hay una regulación para protegernos en
el propio continente estamos expuestos a
propaganda que viene afuera estamos
expuestos a algoritmos que fueron
decididos afuera entonces ponemos en
riesgo a nuestros niños a nuestra gente
a veces la democracia porque puede haber
manipulación por otros intereses y por
personas que deciden por nosotros por
eso es que ahora tenemos un nuevo
continente desde este aspecto de
protección es decir cómo queremos
proteger a un continente
de las redes sociales de la Inteligencia
artificial de todas estas innovaciones
porque a todo ello estamos expuestos y
todo esto puede interferir la educación
de nuestros hijos y en el funcionamiento
de nuestra democracia
tenemos que ser muy inteligentes
sofisticados y coordinados para
establecer un enfoque común
ya ya se empezó esta regulación con la
directiva de Sa pero tenemos que
proteger nuestro modelo y nuestro modelo
europeo
y no dejarlo en manos de intereses
privados no europeos o gobiernos
intereses de gobiernos no europeos y
pienso que este Pilar de protección es
muy importante
el cuarto Pilar de nuestra doctrina es
la reciprocidad
esto constituye en un contexto
de un enfoque
más
benéfico para todas las partes
esta reciprocidad
es exigente a nivel europeo a veces es
difícil admitirlo
Pero ha habido evolución en este aspecto
se requirieron los diez años para que la
Unión Europea adoptara instrumentos para
las compras
internacionales en esto se requiere
reciprocidades porque esta hay una
implicación una implicación compleja de
intereses nacionales en la Unión Europea
y a veces los puntos ofensivos de
algunos países no coinciden con los
puntos defensivos de otros países
queremos que el mercado cree empleos
para esto se requiere reciprocidad y
quiero insistir en el hecho de que la
reciprocidad
será clave especialmente para las nuevas
generaciones del comercio está el
mercosur y hay otros acuerdos
comerciales
con otras partes del mundo yo creo en la
apertura pienso que el comercio fue muy
benéfico y favorable para los europeos y
muy favorable para muchos lugares del
mundo y una de las mejores maneras de
luchar contra la pobreza ha sido el
comercio pero se requiere el comercio
justo y la reciprocidad entre las partes
estos acuerdos de libre comercio
a veces van más allá de la pura lógica
económica y hay tres puntos básicos
primero la sostenibilidad Es simplemente
imposible concebir que en nuestra
política comercial de la Unión Europea
no sea sostenible totalmente tenemos que
aceptar acuerdos de comercio con
gobiernos y con personas
Que no respetan nuestras reglas es decir
algo que obligue a nuestros productores
a seguir nuestros compromisos pero
también obligarlos a importar productos
que vienen de países menos exigentes
realmente es este es un enfoque de doble
filo porque no se respeta lo que uno
cree uno acaba con las Industrias
nacionales
entonces dejemos esto ahí
pero
hay nuevos acuerdos que Serían como el
patrón oro
de los acuerdos comerciales es decir se
requeriría una cláusula esencial
no como algo bonito como un adorno en un
ponque no una cláusula esencial de los
acuerdos comerciales sería el respeto
del cambio climático y el respeto a la
biodiversidad el segundo es la justicia
y el equilibrio
en la economía de la Unión Europea sobre
todo en algunos sectores sensibles y
Cómo serían Los acuerdos para la Unión
Europea
por ejemplo para materiales como
contribuir efectivamente
a la diversificación de los suministros
europeos en sectores claves sí Pero
además de todo esto lo que
definitivamente Necesitamos
es un mecanismo espejo Para estar
seguros que cuando ponemos restricciones
ante nuestros productores también
debemos estar seguros de que las mismas
restricciones se aplican a los países
con Quienes se han firmado Los acuerdos
Esta es la única manera de proteger a
nuestros productores y a nuestra gente
Mi último punto sobre esta doctrina se
refiere a la cooperación
tenemos que promover nuestras agentes
agendas para varias cooperaciones
para asegurar nuestro papel multilateral
para promover este mueble europeo a
nivel internacional
en cuanto a la cooperación tenemos que
ser quienes revitalicemos y extendamos
este marco multilateral
tenemos que promover y promover esta
agenda
pero por ejemplo contra la pesca ilegal
en 2022
o sea aquí tenemos la participación de
la Organización Mundial del Comercio
tenemos que estar de acuerdo para
adoptar mecanismos justos en caso de
conflicto
Esto es lo que se requiere para un mundo
más abierto y más sostenible
también se requiere un alto estándar de
valores con terceros países
la parte externa del mercado único
europeo es importante
hemos comenzado ya
a trabajar en utilizar estos
instrumentos por ejemplo para combatir
la deforestación para fomentar la
producción
de materias primas
si creamos una especie de condición de
acceso a nuestro mercado único algunas
veces es el hecho de que se coopera con
base en una agenda que se considera
esencial todo esto contribuirá a la
mayor eficiencia y en cuanto a los
derechos fundamentales
sabemos lo importante que esto es
la diligencia de vida
y demás principios conocidos pienso que
este enfoque cooperativo debe ser el que
usemos también para que todos trabajemos
juntos que haya un equipo de la Unión
Europea para las agencias de desarrollo
los el banco europeo
para que todas estas partes jueguen
juntas
con base en el interés de nuestros
valores y promoverlos frente a los
países de los terceros países este es la
condición para la mayor eficiencia Este
es el enfoque que queremos promover para
nuestros modelos de desarrollo para que
todos los europeos trabajen juntos como
pueden ver con estos cinco Pilares la
competitividad del mercado único la
política Industrial la protección la
reciprocidad y la cooperación podemos
establecer una nueva doctrina económica
que nos permitirá reconciliar la
creación de empleos con financiados con
nuestro modelo social manejar enfrentar
el cambio social el cambio climático Y
ser más soberanos
pienso que esto es crítico
en esta época difícil en que tenemos
Guerra y en donde la economía se está
convirtiendo en un arma y nuestra
economía será progresivamente parte de
la seguridad nacional y pienso que esto
es crítico porque tenemos que preservar
nuestro modelo de apertura tenemos que
seguir siendo abiertos y baja basarnos
en este enfoque del modelo del mercado
de capitales pero no quiero no queremos
depender de otros y si queremos
preservar nuestros valores
y nuestro modelo europeo basado en el
humanismo y en el apego a la libertad y
a la solidaridad
aquí en el instituto Nexus hace unos 20
años
dio un discurso importante sobre Europa
dijo
que
que Europa estaba hecha de una mezcla de
personas
que era como un café decían y creo en
este espíritu del del café
él decía que para luchar desde Lisboa
hasta todas las demás partes o sea es
los cafés son los tipos donde la gente
acude son los sitios en donde las
personas comparten opiniones
y expresan sus opiniones
pero es también un lugar en donde se
sueña Europa está hecha de sueños pero
nuestros soñadores son pragmáticos
Entonces ahora quiero terminar con un
sueño de los demás por los demás yo soy
un soñador Pero no quiero que mis sueños
se han soñados en lenguajes de otras
personas quiero que nuestra música sea
tocada en todas partes quiero que
nuestra literatura
sea tema de discusión permanente entre
las diferentes capitales de nuestro
continente una de las características de
este continente es precisamente
que hay tantos idiomas pero al mismo
tiempo de una manera estamos siempre
[Música]
moviéndonos entre esta traducción
permanente es complejidad unidad y
respeto y al mismo tiempo diversidad
todo esto tenemos que preservarlo si
queremos
restablecer Este modelo económico O sea
la soberanía europea no es solo un
concepto o una fantasía
es necesario en este mundo
para que todo sea verde para todos como
europeos
[Aplausos]